hi alienjohn here so just the other week
I was hanging out with Drex and Charlie
and DC and we posted a video uh
extolling the virtues of coming to
kinetic fire
I have an addendum to make to uh the
workshops I'm going to be teaching it
turns out that Noel Yi and I have joined
forces and we're going to be co-teaching
to POI workshops and you guys should
totally come and take our workshops
we're going to be teaching stall Chasers
stacks and pendulums
and we're also going to be teaching
pulse weaves body tracers and POI snakes
and with our powers combined it's going
to be some really fun classes and now
I'm back in Boulder hanging out with
Nikki Evers who is also going to be at
kinetic fire and one more reason why you
guys should all come and play with us
and so you should totally check out what
Nikki's offering as well
hello my name is Nikki Evers I'm from
Boulder Colorado I'm a koi spinner and
general flow artist and joyful person of
the world I'm getting really excited for
kinetic fire it's coming up in two weeks
at the end of the first year and her
first year event it's got a huge
concentration of really good talent from
all over the world
I'm going to be teaching two workshops
there the one the first one is going to
be called introduction to Tai Chi
relationship with large it's gonna be
exploring introducing first principle of
Tai Chi which is relaxation and how to
enhance our experience and our Grace and
our learning process and spinning things
thank you
sometimes my thoughts go astray and I
lose my place I drift Inside Out of
Space and drink up the Milky Way you can
see a trace of it in my face as I kick
back and relax in a galaxy far far away
but my doctor said Mark you know you're
crazy I mean you're awfully lazy
and your purpose on this planet's all
hazy if you just kept that receipt you
can take that brain you bought back at
that dream of thought back on track by
eating some mobile prescribed Prozac
doctor I confess I live in Sandy and
I'll be there if you need me so you
should know
second Workshop is going to be called
introduction to plane bending movements
body tracing and other large movements
it's going to be exploring non-linear
movements of poi things that kind of
enhance and imply more of the dance body
movement in their employ spinning
foreign
Congress should make no law respecting
an establishment of religion or
prohibiting the free exercise thereof or
abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press or the right of the people
peacefully to assemble and petition the
government for redress of grievances
I can't wait to meet the Midwest flow
community and I can't wait to see you
all out there and have a lot of fun see
you there
and you find that most of the Flies
oh